For months now, it's been nothing but hype
for Avengers: Endgame.
But some fans' steady enthusiasm took a slight
dip in the days leading up to the theatrical
launch of the superhero epic, when they learned
that Endgame would go against the Marvel movie
grain and not feature a post-credits scene.
We're treading into spoiler territory, both
for the experience of watching Avengers: Endgame
on the big screen and for the movie itself.
If you haven't yet seen the film and want
to walk in without knowing a single thing,
turn your attention away now.
Last warning!
Many who saw the film in early screenings
got a bit up in arms over the lack of an end-credits
stinger, but as it turns out, there are a
few very intriguing reasons why it's still
worth staying in your seat to watch the Endgame
credits the whole way through.
After the beautiful closing shot of Endgame
fades to black, the credits start to roll.
Important names like Joe and Anthony Russo,
the directors of Infinity War and Endgame,
and Kevin Feige, the president of Marvel Studios
who has produced all of the films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, pop up on screen.
Then, where a mid-credits scene would normally
fit, there's a gorgeous tribute to the principal
cast and guest stars of Endgame.
Everyone you know and love is featured, except
for the six main Avengers, who get their own
special tribute.
Iron Man actor Robert Downey Jr., Captain
America star Chris Evans, Thor actor Chris
Hemsworth, Bruce Banner/Hulk star Mark Ruffalo,
Black Widow actress Scarlett Johansson, and
Hawkeye actor Jeremy Renner each get heartwarming
video tributes featuring breathtaking new
artwork.
The stars' signatures swipe across the screen,
making for an homage both well-deserved and
quite emotional, particularly considering
the events of Avengers: Endgame that viewers
witnessed just before.
But that's not all!
The credits don't entirely resume to business
as usual from there on.
We advise audiences keep their butts in their
seats until the lights come on, lest they
miss an expertly placed MCU Easter egg at
the tail end of the credits.
Right when it seems no other moviemaking details
will scroll on screen, keep your ears open.
Immediately after the Marvel logo appears,
where a true post-credits scene would traditionally
be placed, a familiar sound rings out...
It may seem inconsequential to some, but for
die-hard Marvel fans, this sound effect means
a great deal.
Tony making an enormous sacrifice for the
greater good in Avengers: Endgame, something
that the genius-billionaire-playboy-philanthropist
likely would have never done in his earlier
years, means the MCU as viewers have known
it thus far ends with Iron Man as well.
The split-second sound lets Iron Man be the
stopping point just as he was the starting
one all those years ago.
Though it may not be a full-on post-credits
scene as Marvelites are used to seeing, it's
arguably more poignant than those sequences
have ever been.
With Avengers: Endgame forgoing a post-credits
scene, the MCU is sailing ahead without any
dangling threads trailing behind it.
The franchise isn't ready to begin its fourth
phase just yet, as Feige has stated that it's
actually the Spidey sequel Spider-Man: Far
From Home that marks the end of the third
phase, so there is technically one future
in-phase film to tease.
However, Endgame is the coming-together of
the MCU's 11-year saga, and it would feel
incredibly silly to tack on a sequence setting
up Spider-Man's next adventure: one, because
he wasn't in the movie until the final act,
and two, because a Spidey-centered tease would
be pretty jarring to see after the emotional
rollercoaster that was Endgame.
Marvel will leave the Phase 4-teasing up to
Far From Home when that film swings into theaters
this July, and everyone is better for it.
Before then, though, re-watch Endgame as many
times as your heart desires, and be on alert
for the small but significant sound at the
end of the credits.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.